[Music]  how much money you went to me for ed  [Applause]  126 that's 504 quarters  don't steal from me  building an apartment complex putting in  every dime we're putting in our own  sweat  but we're coming up short everything i  got is in that renovation  that's our future  [Music]  where's the money coming from europe  he's a very dangerous man  he's a criminal he's our only choice  you need money you only say seven  hundred thousand  thank you  guy like him is after much more every  day i don't have my money  add on 20  we got to pay  can't he wants full ownership of nikki  and i's property  he threatened to kill us  have i made my point  you want me to kill him  who do you think won we have to end this  [Music]  [Music]  you